thank you
all right the stars are known to bring
out their most daring and award-worthy
looks on the Golden Globes red carpet
but did they deliver last night well
here to answer that question is our own
Susie wall who joins us once again from
Vancouver to break down all of the
fashion triumphs misses and the ones
that were just so so and Susie good
morning overall uh what'd you think of
last night's looks on the red carpet you
know what you guys the red carpet
fashion is definitely back but was it
the tidal wave of sort of bombshell and
glamor and theatrics and over the top
that we were expecting not so much for
me I'm hoping that this is just a
precursor to what will be Mega at the
Oscars so for me I give it a meh but
still some great looks to talk about
overall you're giving it one of these
the so-so yeah yeah okay yeah okay we
had a group text yeah we had a group
text going on last night and I I'm on
the same page I was kind of like
nothing's really blowing me away but uh
there was no shortage of Sparkle Susie
tons of Sparkle and very celebratory at
that I think we've got a couple to start
with do we have uh Angela Bassett to
begin with yes okay look at how strong
and fit she looks I like this halter
neckline I thought she looked beautiful
for me you know she was a Triumph I
don't know how you guys feel uh and
Jennifer Coolidge I stole the show I
think that the globe should send her a
gift basket today she was hilarious she
I mean she dominated the night for me I
was in stitches I don't know what did
you guys think these were both sort of
yeah yeah great right yeah exactly yeah
I agree
Coolidge is a great example too of just
you know what just have fun and tell
some good jokes and be a nice person and
make people laugh and you're gonna look
gorgeous like really pretty from the
inside out so I I love her yeah they
both won in fashion and they actually
took home some Hardware last night in
their categories exactly very cool all
right what's our next board
Jessica Chastain okay and Jennifer
Hudson so I loved Jessica Chastain's
look I love this clamshell dress uh I
love the beauty I'm a redhead girl so I
would have loved to see those locks down
with a deep wide part slick uh just to
be able to it's such a shocking color in
person it's literally copper so that
would be my only miss on her and then
Jennifer Hudson I love this kind of mock
neckline and the mirror sequins the
beauty was a hit for me they're both a
Triumph are you guys with me
yep love them both and love the look
absolutely
oh where's the Miss oh no yeah Chastain
Chastain was a Miss for me Susie I just
it didn't do it for me the dress I was
trying I was hoping I was wishing and I
just I couldn't I couldn't uh make it
happen for me but Jennifer was a total
Triumph 10 out of 10. I get it she could
have got a deeper red lip that's what I
think what it would have taken Chastity
note for the top okay who do we have
next Cheryl Lee Ralph okay and Michelle
yo winner okay both of these women I
thought looked phenomenal I love that we
have them side by side uh confident
gorgeous I thought that Michelle's
speech was absolutely lovely
um and Cheryl Lee on the carpet was so
engaging uh they're both triumphs for me
what did you guys think
how can it not be a Triumph when you're
posing with your statue with the right
I mean it's a very definite definite
Triumph yeah
for the girls I thought they were
phenomenal another Trend we spotted on
the red carpet last night coyotes cut
outs are still in
cutouts are still Mega hot yeah and we
had some real bombshell looks I think
this was my favorite category so first
let's begin well okay uh Jenna Ortega
I'm obsessed with her she was a total
Gucci goddess for me and taupe I love
the wing of the eyeliner she's got this
kind of Rosie Perez a little bit of
Marissa Tomei she's like this modern
anje new I loved this tone it's
difficult to pull off and I think that
she absolutely nailed it and this red
cutout for me you know bombshell Lily
looking absolutely old Hollywood glamor
what did you guys think so much fabric
on this gown I loved the red both the
Triumph yeah I mean they were so hot I
just thought those two read the
invitation they're young they're modern
they're sexy but they're still
appropriate so I thought they both
nailed it and I can't wait to see what
they're wearing for the Oscars Lily
James getting 600 000 Instagram
followers a day in the last few weeks so
she's mega mega mega star no not Lily
James I'm sorry Ortega Jenna Wednesday I
mean she is just going through the roof
fun social she is the it girl of the
moment so for her I'm actually the most
excited to see what she's going to do at
Oscars you know what I feel like there's
so many good looks at last night's
globes that I need a holder for this
just keep the trying sign up who hit the
red carpet dramatically
you know I'm gonna say Michelle Williams
I know I was pouting how much I love her
and how amazing she is and I'm still
gonna give her a Triumph on this one I
thought she looked really cool some
people are saying the dress were her it
kind of did I'm gonna but I still stand
by my girl Quinta with the fit and flare
and the bright pops of pink a little bit
of red undertone in there I thought she
was a total Triumph I'm going to give
them both the green yeah I mean if we're
voting on drama being dramatic for sure
that's a Triumph I'm a so-so on this one
um
yeah when it comes to Michelle it you
have to hit that dress in a certain
light with a certain angle if you don't
it can be very straight and like you
said you can get lost in the Ruffles
absolutely a nice problem to have but
nonetheless okay who do we have next oh
my gosh two Purple Rain and queens I
absolutely love Selena Gomez and it was
kind of this kind of Cape is it a glove
is it a stole I loved her look and uh
yeah Niecy Nash I love that shade of
Plum to me she was Mega I mean she could
have fit into any of our categories for
bold color or Sparkle or volume and
drama so they were both a green card for
me how about you that's pretty easy
Selena a Miss for me and not anything
against Selena a more her style is Susie
I just I just don't I don't know if that
dress complemented Selena all right I'm
splitting the difference so so for them
both all right put it on thermostat who
do we have next
okay Julia Garner bubble gum pink uh
Gucci uh for me she was yeah a bit
country singer I didn't enjoy the tears
uh and the bustier I think she's a Super
Rad woman and I love seeing what she
brings Rihanna velvet Diamonds the
bustier the drama the high volume stole
I mean she really stole the show I love
that they kept shouting out to her so
for me I'm gonna give Julia a Miss sadly
and uh Rihanna Triumph yeah agreed yeah
I agree with you on that for sure
absolutely okay we didn't see a lot of
color on the red carpet last night to
Susie but there were just a couple of uh
celebs who dress a little on the
brighter side yeah we have Anya Taylor
Joy here striking in kind of a lemon
meringue we got the ab flashing outfit
coordinating going on she and her
partner arrived looking pretty rock star
and then we have uh Viola Davis in
Vancouver raised Jason Wu I know New
York tries to take credit for him Taiwan
foreign Regal in this shade of Royal uh
let's go to our paddles I'm going to say
so so on both of these yeah oh
interesting no I don't know I was very
meh on these two
um okay Anya's got a great kind of a
very editorial look very fashion look
but they were both sort of so-so okay
okay
what do you think of Margo
oh my God Margot okay
um I was disappointed in her beauty I
like to see her blonde and bomb Shelly I
didn't like the darker hair I wasn't
that happy with the Lesser eye uh
something like a thousand hours went
into this dress uh which is amazing and
impressive but I think she's ramping up
to her Barbie moment Seth Rogen needs no
notes Vancouver raised again in pink I
think this was Gucci now this was Dior I
loved him so I'm going to give Seth a
Triumph and I'm going to give Margo a
Miss although Margot to sit with Pitt so
she wins
yeah they're two of my favorites I don't
care what they're wearing I give them
both a Triumph love them both so okay
let's talk uh men's fashion if we could
uh just finally uh here and we're going
to start with a big winner from last
night Elvis himself Austin Butler
Austin Butler in a Gucci suit I loved
his Cartier Rings we were talking about
how he'd be so out there in Super
fashion and groundbreaking and you know
he just went right down Broadway like I
said Carol Colin Farrell would so who's
to know he's got a little bit of a pop
here but I thought he looked wonderful
um and then we have Jeremy Pope wearing
a full leather suit and a diamond
necklace full props so I can give these
guys both a Triumph oh okay yep Jeremy
the Triumph I'm gonna give Austin the
so-so because uh you know when you come
and you win for Elvis maybe you expect a
little more Sparkles rhinestones
something like that but there's nothing
wrong with classic at the same time true
I know I I get what you're saying though
but neck up he's definitely a try okay
next anybody else
all right
favorite dudes okay Billy Porter went
viral last night bringing back that
tuxedo dress that he's so infamously
wore just a few years ago with the
platform rhinestone boots I absolutely
loved it and Donald Glover I'm thrilled
to know Childish Gambino has not been
retired the San Laura cream Lounge
two-piece fairy Hugh Hefner
um a very out there but somehow randomly
it worked for me I don't know you guys
what do you say
Superstars Triumph I think
Donald I
won
I I'd like to bore that right totally I
would love that you could wear that on
the carpet you'd look like an 11 out of
10. I mean Billy is just a groundbreaker
right he's stealing Crusher so I love
them both but yeah overall I'd say I
can't wait till Oscars we have something
to look forward to all right well listen
I think we can raise this paddle for
Susie wall always a Triumph thank you
Susie good to see you this morning